MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, my
name is Martin Omander,
and I welcome you to
"Google Root Access,"
the show featuring
actionable start-up advice.
My guest today is
Nathan Beckord.
Welcome on the show, Nathan.
NATHAN BECKORD:
Thanks for having me.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
you are the founder
of the start-up Foundersuite.
NATHAN BECKORD: That's right.
MARTIN OMANDER: Can you tell
us a bit about your startup?
NATHAN BECKORD: Sure.
Foundersuite is a collection
of five web apps and about 80
templates, spreadsheets,
documents, for entrepreneurs.
And the way it came
about is I was consulting
the start-ups here in Silicon
Valley for about 10 years,
usually in a finance
or biz dev capacity,
built a lot of these
spreadsheets, templates,
saw a lot of common patterns
of success and failure.
Worked with about
150 companies, so
got a good pattern recognition
going with start-ups,
and so I decided to
build a tool and document
collection for them.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
150 start-ups-- did
you get any sleep?
NATHAN BECKORD: Not much, no.
You can see, I
still have the bags.
MARTIN OMANDER: So it sounds
like a big part of what you're
doing is providing templates
to the start-ups who
are your customers.
What infrastructure
do use for that?
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah,
so we use Google Drive.
So we have about 80
templates in this collection.
Some examples are like pitch
decks, financial models,
co-founders agreement,
hiring plans,
things like that-- pretty
wide diversity of things.
MARTIN OMANDER: Important stuff
that a lot of start-ups forget.
NATHAN BECKORD: Very
important stuff,
and you can screw up your
company if you do things wrong.
So we're trying to
provide some structure.
These templates are in a
variety of file formats,
as you can probably imagine,
from Keynote, PowerPoint,
Excel, PDF, all over the board.
And we use Google Drive
to store them all.
We originally chose Google Drive
because it was quick and dirty.
It was kind of a hack to get
started with our document
storage.
But we've stayed on it.
MARTIN OMANDER: I
like quick hacks.
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah, yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: But
you stayed on it.
How come?
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah,
because it works for us,
because it works great.
It's very reliable,
and we enjoy it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So when I go into
your app, I've seen
how there are directories for my
stage of start-up and all that,
and I can click through, and I
get a listing of the templates.
When I do that, what
happens in the background?
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah, so our
software is pinging Drive's API
to see what files are
in our corporate folder.
And then our software is
presenting all these files
in a very beautiful,
navigable way.
So we have a section
of our site that
is all the different templates.
And it's broken into categories
like getting started,
hiring, fund raising,
things like that.
And then also, when you're
working in our web apps,
we have access to these
documents and templates, too.
So for example, if you're
working in our Investor CRM
tool, managing your
discussions with investors,
there's a little tab
on the side that you
can pull up these docs.
Same with the Media CRM
tool, so it's a great way
to navigate what's
stored on Google Drive.
And then the user can simply
open up one of these files
and either store it to
their own Google Drive
or save it to their hard
drive-- very easy to use.
MARTIN OMANDER: So then if they
store it on their own Google
Drive account, you
don't need to deal
with storage space and such.
It is off on their account, and
they have their own version.
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah, we
maintain the master copies
of all these files,
and they make copies
and do what they want with them.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So what does this
integration with Google Drive
bring to you as a keeper
of many documents?
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah,
it's been great.
You know, we don't have
to worry about passwords,
about security.
MARTIN OMANDER: Passwords--
I've been in a start-up
where you spent way too much
time worrying about passwords
rather than our core business.
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah, you
can't let things like passwords
derail your start-up.
That would be horrible.
It lets us not worry about
hosting costs and things
like that.
Google is very reliable.
I can't think of downtime
in the past couple years.
And for me as a CEO, and I'm
also kind of the product guy,
it means that can spend
my time out hunting
for different new documents
to add to the collection,
or we build our own sometimes.
And it's very easy for
me to add new things
to the collection in
the proper folder.
I simply go into our corporate
drive, add the thing,
and then it magically appears
in the user's accounts
and folders, which is great.
I don't get engineers involved.
I don't have to get coders
involved when I just
want to add a new document
to the collection.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So you mentioned
some of the documents
that you were storing,
like co-founder agreements,
like legal agreements,
pitch decks.
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: What other
things are you storing?
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah, we've
got all kinds of good stuff.
We have a lot of
marketing tools.
For example, if you're
looking to do a press release,
we have press release templates
and sample docs for that.
In our Getting Started
section, there's
co-founders agreement,
equity split wizard.
Think of some of the
high profile cases
recently of Snapchat
or even Facebook
where they didn't
have a proper equity
split agreement in
place, and later on,
the third or fourth
co-founder sues.
Getting that stuff right
early on is important.
In our finance section, there's
some planning templates,
financial models,
hiring planners,
so you can kind of
map out who you're
planing to hire over
the next 12 months.
There's things like
terms of service and kind
of boilerplate things
that most start-ups need.
Hiring-- we have NDAs,
contractor agreements,
things like that, yeah,
a lot of good stuff.
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds like a
treasure trove of useful stuff.
NATHAN BECKORD: It is.
I'm very proud of it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So finally, what
would your advice
be, Nathan, to a
start-up that needs
to store a document as
a part of their service?
NATHAN BECKORD: Sure.
It's pretty simple.
Play to your strengths, play
to what your start-up does,
and piggyback on the
talented army of engineers
here at Google to manage
storage, passwords, security.
There's no reason to
reinvent the wheel.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, yes.
I've seen it
reinvented many times,
and not always very well.
NATHAN BECKORD: Yeah, well, it's
been a great foundation for us.
We've been on this
almost two years now.
And it's been super
reliable, fast, easy,
and it saves us money.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
NATHAN BECKORD: I just hope that
you guys keep your servers on.
That's my one request to you.
Just keep those servers lit
up, and we're all happy.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh yes.
After we shut down
the cameras, I'll
go in and talk to the guys.
NATHAN BECKORD: Good, good.
MARTIN OMANDER:
All right, great.
Thank you so much for
coming on the show
and sharing your
experience with us, Nathan.
NATHAN BECKORD:
Thanks for having me.
Appreciate it.
MARTIN OMANDER: We hope
you found something
you can use in your start-up.
Your input matters.
Please leave your
comments below.
We read everything you write.
To learn how Google
can help your start-up,
go to
developers.google.com/startups.
If you would like to
be a guest on the show,
go to bit.ly/applyrootaccess.
That's it for now.
See you next time.